eu já vi
e aí
o futuro
o futuro para mim agora
e não não espera
já chegou
o que disse isso foi chico science não
entrevista e essa frase me marcou
profundamente porque por mais que seja ó
viu
e não é normal pensar dessa maneira não
comenta em quando refletimos sobre o
futuro visualizamos como algo
relativamente distante
é mas no fundo não tem
já chegou de novo e já passou
e essa fragilidade dos segundos que faz
com que a gente não dê a devida
importância esses micro-momentos
é mas da mesma forma como não entramos
duas vezes no mesmo rio esse futuro
acabou de passar ele era único nunca
mais se repetirá
e é natural planejar o futuro observar
as tendências mentir se preparar para
tudo ficar pronto para essa chegada
o quanto melhor a estratégia mais
evitaremos os tropeços
oi e aí podemos seguir reto
é mas aí vem quintana e lembra que a
curva é o caminho mais agradável e dois
pontos
e nos fazendo lembrar que é exatamente
no deslizar sinuoso das notas musicais
que se faz um bom jazz
é provavelmente o futuro planejado por
muitos aqui hoje vai ser modificado
depois desse encontro ou amanhã talvez
conhecendo alguém caminho de uma padaria
é isso porque os nossos dias são
desenhados pelo acaso não dá para
ignorar uma então de nível entendi
e é preciso também estabelecer conexões
com aquilo que não pode ser medido
programar e planejar tudo é esquecer
o que os computadores não hesitam eles
não reajam ainda esperado
o bom mesmo é exercitar a demora do
olhar contemplar o cotidiano se vestir
de domingo às vezes só para sair um
pouco dessa eu furei a social agora é
fácil isso não não é fácil até porque o
crescimento exponencial das coisas vem
nos deixando tontos e despertando as
cidades eu eu não sei vocês mas eu não
lembro de tantas farmácias na rua quando
brincávamos de identificar forma sem
nuvens
e hoje tudo é muito rápido e o discurso
por uma capacitação permanente na cada
vez mais interativo
é mas não podemos nos distanciar das
tendências certo
nós temos que correr mas não tem uma
coisa
e a natureza não se desenvolve
exponencialmente
o e pasmem
nós somos parte dela
em resumo
e de forma natural não damos conta dessa
pressa toda se quiser me seguir a
velocidade que disse que a gente precisa
teremos que usar condimentos que se
distanciam dos nossos temperos naturais
e aí a vida vai criando outro sabor para
saber se quisermos realmente a tão
ocupados assim vamos estar abrindo mão
da presença e deixando de firmar
vínculos fundamentais nesse processo e
vou dizer não há nada mais estruturante
do que o afeta
e agora o danado é que essa corrida para
o futuro tem começado a cada vez mais
cedo eu tenho dois filhos pequenos e
sinto uma pressão gigante por treiná-los
para vida
e é cada vez mais exigente e
transformaram a infância como se fosse
um estágio para ser adulto
é mas fazendo crer que eles estão
criança como assim estão criança lição
crianças eles não estão em fase de
capacitação para ser alguém eles são
alguém e com a capacidade enorme para
nos ensinar
e vai super rir sobre dizer onde é que
tá esse problema é que todas as pessoas
grandes foram um dia crianças mas poucas
se lembram disso
e depois é a gente vai crescendo e os
rótulos vão diminuindo o sinal de
cobertura que a gente tem com a infância
e esse mês mesmo início estávamos no
carro no trânsito parado sobre uma
chovendo homem
oi e aí flagramos o nosso filho mais
novo joão de um ano vidrado na janela
olhando a água escorrer pelo vidro
e olha lá filhão que chuva forte lá fora
e aí o mais velho na hora ponto o
e é melhor imaginação do que o óbvio
dando-se como assim é tudo que ele
poderia estar pensando antes agora virou
apenas chuva caindo lá fora
o silêncio do carro
oi e ele ainda emendou como se achasse
pouco cantarolando los hermanos a
estrada vai além do que se vê
e veja descondicionar um olhar é o
primeiro passo para captar os momentos
sem vícios
e é preciso mudar o ângulo de observação
percebem e aí espinosa escreveu
exatamente isso que o espírito é eterno
na medida que consegue as coisas do
ponto de vista da eternidade e foi
exatamente quando engravidamos de pedro
o mais velho hoje com 18 anos que essa
reflexão passou a fazer muito mais
sentido para gente
e de repente uma praça passou a compor a
paisagem mesmo estando ali o tempo
inteiro
o parceiro e vendendo comida aos peixes
no lago dela e música e simples passar a
me emocionar
e as cores que foram se aquecendo no
entorno e já quando nasceu nas primeiras
consultas com o pediatra assim como quem
busca no google queremos respostas
rápidas pode falar nós que estavam aqui
já aparecendo eu tô ele não para de
chorar
e ele não quer mamar quer que a gente
faz por favor
e aí ele abriu um sorriso com os olhos e
respondeu afetivamente se vocês que são
os pais não sabem como é que eu vou
saber
em conversa com o filho de vocês sim
então
oi e aí ele começou a mexer com a chave
importante na gente que nós conector
ainda mais o mundo do nosso filho
o tanto que no dia congelei a ouvir de
um desenho animado que são alisava o
café da manhã olha lá peixes voadores eu
disse opa eu imaginei que os peixes
tinha decidido a mudar de vida e sair em
bando e uma imagem mais ou menos assim
se desenhou na minha mente eu digo
aquela
e aqui no aquecimento das cores que
estavam nos lugares agora já estavam
dentro de mim e isso me ajudou muito
numa noite que ele confessou que não
tava conseguindo dormir porque tinha
visto um livro com a imagem muito feia
na escola ele dizia papai quando você se
os olhos a imagem vem tô conseguindo
dormir não aí eu comia experiência de
vida adulto diz filho relaxa isso não
existe é só uma história aí ele existe
sim papai aqui dentro
e aí eu corri me lancei' no mundo dele e
vi o que existe lá suco é que a gente
faz o seguinte fecha os olhos e deixa
ela vir quando ela chegar a gente arruma
logo o cabelo dela certa pega o escova
pega o batom vamos pintar vamos maquiar
e aí ele foi rindo e dormiu
e já em outro dia enquanto andávamos
pela rua ele constatou papai o sol
tifoide é mais gentil do que o sol
aquele recife
e como assim não é que lá 8 horas da
noite ainda tá claro ele deixa a gente
brincar por mais tempo
eu vejo as crianças elas se conecta com
os momentos de forma inteira planos
refletem muito sobre o antes o suco
depois elas vivem e pronto e para viver
com ela se sentir é preciso estar lá
naquele agora por um ponto de vista
delas
e eu tenho treinado isso eu tenho tido
cuidado que ta observando mas não
escapei tem um dia em que recebi um
conselho dele enquanto brincávamos ele
ele percebeu que eu estava impaciente
despeço ele disse papai você precisa
esvaziar a mente mas proteger em casa
nem buda né e aí realmente eu não tava
naquele momento com ele
eu tava em qualquer tempo e em qualquer
lugar menos ali naquele agora
é fácil não é fácil a gente pode
exercitar isso e eu queria fazer essa
exercício com vocês
se você precisa de uma realmente eu vou
ilustrar apoiado no cliente diz que sem
a música a vida seria um erro
e eu vou utilizar a música para ilustrar
isso imaginemos que por que a vida fosse
um jeito certo observe bem isso
e ela sugere o facebook e cria um
cenário que vai servir como referência
então é como se fosse o ponto de partida
do nosso ponto de retorno sabe quando a
gente brincava na rua em casa e que a
gente tava lá passar o dia todo fora
qualquer problema correia para casa
pudesse ele faz isso ele cria toda a
referência tudo a base ea partir dela
ele perguntou quem era ele tem a nossa
liberdade imaginativa e criativa mas
sempre respeitando essa base então vocês
vão perceber que nessa música
determinado momento ele está criando
livre mestre pra gente vai poder ouvir
atrás toda a base que sustenta ele agora
por exemplo
e ele tá criando mas eu sou um atrás
em toda base ela tá sustentando o que
ele tá improvisando
e se a vida ela assim como dias assim
losa envolvente e intrigante eu teria
que a paternidade chega para aquecer
mais as cores em significa o sentido do
tempo
a e trazer uma multiplicidade rítmica
bem pernambucana quero ver
e vamos imaginar
o que a natureza pulsasse da seguinte
maneira
e aí
e quantas notas filhos chegam é como se
estivéssemos entrando numa marcha de
bloco pela primeira vez
nós não sabemos como dança como canta
mas estamos ali no meio de uma
experiência completamente nova sendo que
atuar e bem o deslumbramento
e aí vamos tentar observar os mais
experientes para aprender com seus
movimentos mas entendemos que a beleza
está o que diferente indicado e cada um
e aí vai perdendo a timidez você vai
fazer uma espaço jeito beijos agente é
libertador
e essa certeza vai nos dando uma lei
valência que nos leis de cima a entrar
numa roda de coco e aí vamos pisando
cada vez mais fortes no chão sorrinfo
graciosamente pela certeza das
habilidades adquiridas
ah mas então
e parece um vídeo e salvos autorizar os
passos deles
em que tudo vira uma capoeira esse
brinquedo é meu essa tensão é minha
corre daqui cai de lá cuidado o celular
toca é da escola meu deus do céu
é mas aí a gente entende que é hora de
abrir os braços
e pedir ajuda
a puxar uma ciranda com facinho os
bancos descalços vamos sim quando é luz
o tipos abastecendo de afeto e sabendo
que não estamos só essa fogueira e
e isso dá uma certeza tão grande né
gente que nosso feito estufa como rei e
rainha que o maracatu entendemos que
nosso cortejo o nosso brincantes precisa
ter liberdade para atuar e criança suas
próprias coreografias e
e se essa certeza vamos nos criando
perdendo os passistas totalmente livre
entendendo que mesmo os momentos de
terror
a operação convite de uma nova dança ela
percebe o ritmo ali pulsando cozinhando
é o mesmo é
olá tudo mundo tem o seu disco você
trata de acelerar ou desacelerar a vida
podem ser lançadas e diferente de
maneiras faça porque a gente que se
conecte à encontrem o pulso de vocês
natural respeito e ele e sinto uma
eternidade que existe em cada um desses
compactos mas
o final quanto tempo dura o eterno
e às vezes apenas um segundo
bom obrigado
e aí
ah tá